[Music]
hello my name is Scott Ellesmere and I'm
a plication xand technology team manager
at HK technologies and while I'd like to
do right now is give you an overview
through the Mitsubishi control is
featured on all our wire EDM series so
welcome to the Mitsubishi advanced +3
control 3 real main areas to the control
to set up the program and the monitor
setup area is where the operator sets up
all his work pieces to enable him to do
that we have a selection of pickups for
example work slope weather part will be
orientated in line with the machine's
axis this saves the need for clocking in
the workpiece once he's done this you
might like to do something like a
three-point Center outside inside maybe
just a simple X pickup to find find it a
datum or maybe he has a plate where he's
picking up off off a corner and you can
simply tell it where he wants to pick up
around the part and where to move to
with the wire to insert the wire once
he's found his part he might like to do
a program several ways of getting any I
just file DXF file into the machine
either by network or by USB so the first
thing you might do is open up
is file and here we have a pair of solid
you might like to sample the outline so
we're outside and sample the outline
that's been transferred through to the
2d cam and once he has this all in
Finkley has to do is to select a point
for a thread point then we can start to
apply the process so we move into cam
specify our thread location the
workpiece and then we set the conditions
the operator simply works his way
through through the panel answering all
the questions until he achieves the
surface finish and desired result in
within the technology that he's looking
for we searched for the technology you
can see here is generator settings
offset stepping increments and we save
this to the camp system it then decides
whether he has divert Punk shape whether
he has one part multiple parts and his
basic strategy that he wants to use we
apply that to the process and then we
can create the NC program and at this
point you can open the editor if you
want to do any editing or checking of
the program but faith basically and very
simply you can move straight through to
the monitor screen where is then able to
start cutting the workpiece and now the
program is ready to run in the
background while the machine is running
we have a multitude of technology
enhancements that are taken care of the
process for him for example looking
after corners in the rough cut but also
in skin cut where the wire can be forced
more into the corners or in the case of
punching machine in take more of the
radius to say lay the bench work all bit
master takes care of differences in
shapes between straight surface and
round surface for us and these are just
a couple of the tools that are working
in the background to support the
operator of course sometimes we need to
do a little bit of maintenance on the
machine so we have some maintenance
timers that tell the operator when he
should add lubrication oil or changed
filters and how much why maybe he's got
left on the job for the evening the
threading management in real time
follows the wire threader through the
system and should there be a problem
it's very easy for the operator to come
in enter the guide system
where he gets a PDF view of what what if
what he might need to do to rectify any
issue so that's just a real basic
introduction into the Mitsubishi control
and how simple it is to get an operation
running
[Music]